um
then i have to keep coming out
hold it
now what i want to show you here is a
powerful man the finger thing i come
here
you come here
pretty close to
[Music]
to think how many pieces of your
and um
this is what makes the consensus
powerful itself
coordination of all kings
please
i slide it down here
because i don't want it to go now this
wants to keep flat if it's up here
then he'll determine
if he turns over or not
if you can so if it's up here and you go
i'm gonna get this you just literally
what he doesn't ignore they don't
normally resist
that linkage they will resist that
language or that leverage but they don't
send them for some reason
that legal joint so if it's too upright
this this is out
this this is flat
if it's up
forget it you won't get it
don't go flat
keep it there just a little pressure and
like a bouncing ball
push release
and that release is what he wants he
wants to fight back
so that little fight back gives you like
a spring and you can even do the
technique
here
[Laughter]
so let's do this